and yeah white chose not to go five but  once this happens like you  your position is just so completely  broken in in strategic terms that  it's just very very difficult to recover  and yeah  the zambian player tried to launch some  kind of an attack on the king's side but  it was never likely to succeed with  black having this monster on e4  yeah just no targets  yeah  and yeah white you know is almost about  to create a threat but he actually kind  of gets mated in the meantime so that  threat never materializes  yeah and then bishop d3 um so yeah  magnus one and the match in general  there stands really really well because  johan sebastian is  uh you know much better slash winning uh  yondu the camera is also doing really  well on board too yeah everything  everything is going well there  for norway at least  today they seem to be having things